All right guys, so this is going to be the final example for the strategy, so as you can see, we made hi, high, low, low, sorry, higher.
then we're going to lower high, lower low, lower low, lower low,
then we're going to higher high, higher low, higher high.
And then after we swept the high of the Asian range, which is this,
during the lunch break, we swept the high.
And then we had a market structure shift, as you can see right around here, right?
And then if I mark out the autoblog, this is the autoblog that we have,
Alright, so you would have entered here. You stop should have gone here. If it went there, you would have gotten stopped out
But if you had your stop here, you would have targeted the Asian session range and this would have given you a 3.26
Resto Ward break
So we will be moving on to our next tragedy after this video and
other you guys in the next trading strategy video